[Music]
hiya babe no not at all
hey what's up and so sleazy it's called
it one wheel that's not motorized huh
yeah yeah I got motor inside a wheel
motorized where's your head I know we
don't have one we had it for a video
where we did green-screen heads big
bummer green-screen heads
one of the best parts about doing shoots
is that there's always leftover crafty
there we go yeah right where the gummy
worms you know where they are
but he's not telling us you're messing
with us there isn't one isn't there - it
would be pen ah was there a bucket of
Governor Brown said yesterday there was
a bucket of government 17m why are you
holding out on us you know where they
are you know exactly where they are
where the gummy worms
oh we know whatever they're there the
family Brett's returning hey Brett I
have a very important question to ask
you
when G when you return the van did you
see and gummy worms in there that will
sink a snake
get some have some trips this is the
McGarry call Michael just you and me man
Halloween shopping Carla I don't know if
you know this but this is an incredible
time of the year dude it's Halloween man
Halloween is so special man you there's
this magic in the air i watch this you
feel the Halloween in the air Phil it's
Halloween weatherman it's great telelink
remark yeah I mean I would say I would
more than like how in I get some more of
an obsession you know time of year when
you can eat candy scare people
Oh shake oh my god Halloween man today I
am going to a Halloween store to pick up
a giant skull besides that just taken
back an r2d2 should be a fun little
adventure if we can't get this done
today I was gonna get done Keuchel you
know like Halloween
I'm so so about it yeah
Oh
you want to see a trick that shonduras
Tommy
let me try sure boy dude are you doing
one more did we pass it two miles away
yeah
it looks like the front door though
I see it looks like this whole place is
connected now
No
good this is bliss right now man all
these fun Halloween
it is man
that's the skull
[Applause]
hey what's up man I will get the skull
is there anything else that you want me
to pick up on here it's just the biggest
goal you guys have 1874 I will fix this
[Music]
those are for us to share you and I been
Oh mortar and grew up I don't feel well
hey too many gummy worms
okay no worries they need so much lon
I appreciate it my friend right you're
gonna go to the movies go to Mars is one
of ours man you ready to go you're gonna
be trend to Mars we're gonna do we're
gonna do this did we get everything we
need done yes we did
successful day successful day indeed